vamos a tratar de simplificar la
siguiente expresión racional así que te
invito a que hagas una pausa como
siempre y trates de hacerlo por tu
propia cuenta porque en unos momentos
vamos a hacerlo todos juntos muy bien
entonces lo primero que digamos
podríamos tratar de hacer digo porque no
sé las expresiones que tenemos aquí
parecen sugerir nos que todo esto se
puede factorizar y quizás haya factores
en común que después podamos cancelar
verdad así que por ejemplo no debería
digamos asustarte que aquí vemos una
equis elevada a la cuarta verdad
simplemente en principio puede parecer
difícil pero podemos utilizar ciertos
patrones para ver cómo factorizar el
numerador por ejemplo entonces este tipo
de patrones a los que me refiero sería
algo de este estilo por ejemplo qué tal
que no hubiéramos x 4a sino x cuadrada
8 x 7 si hubiéramos digamos esto déjenme
pintarlo mejor esto es 8x verdad si
viéramos esto uno se preguntaría bueno
cómo podríamos factorizar lo es decir
pensamos en dos números que
multiplicados nos den 7 y sumados nos
den 8 y eso claramente es más 7
más una verdad 7 por 1 771 es 8 ahora
bien en vez de pensar en x pensemos en x
cuadrada que es como lo que aparecería
aquí verdad aquí tendríamos una x
cuadrada y x cuadrada de elevada al
cuadrado sería x a la cuarta verdad
entonces en realidad si pensamos con x
cuadrada lo que tendríamos es x cuadrada
más 7 que multiplica a x cuadrada más 1
verdad entonces quizás si no te gusta
pensarlo como digamos de esta forma
quizás te gustaría hacer una sustitución
digamos llamemos a igual a x cuadrada
verdad entonces aquí lo que tenemos es
cuadrada más 8 a más 7 verdad y entonces
ahora si usamos lo que ya conocemos
verdad podríamos factorizar lo como a
más 7 x
+ 1 y luego podríamos hacer de nuevo la
sustitución de que a es x cuadrada y
obtenemos justamente lo que tenemos aquí
verdad entonces esta es una buena
factorización del numerador vamos a ver
qué ocurre ahora con el denominador
entonces aquí podemos ver que estos dos
términos tienen un factor de 3x así que
vamos a poner 3x y esto multiplica a x a
la cuarta menos 1 muy bien entonces
hasta ahora no parece dejamos ayudar
mucho esta factorización que hemos
obtenido pero todavía podemos
simplificar la expresión x a la cuarta
menos 1 porque porque esto es una
diferencia de cuadrados recordemos que
es una diferencia de cuadrados es cuando
tenemos a cuadrada menos 1 iguala a más
1 por a menos 1 por ejemplo verdad aquí
podría ser otro cuadrado entonces aquí
nosotros tenemos x a la cuarta menos 1
verdad simplemente decimos que hace
x cuadrada y entonces tendríamos x
cuarta menos uno y ese factor iza de
esta forma entonces como como lo
escribiríamos ya digamos tomando a
iguala x cuadrada bueno vamos a dejar
igual el numerador x cuadrada más 7 que
multiplica a x cuadrada más 1 todo esto
dividido entre 3 x x y ahora sí
tendríamos x cuadrada más 1 x cuadrada
más 1 y multiplicada x cuadrada menos 1
muy bien entonces esta es la forma de
factorizar x 4 -1 verdad entonces estos
dos factores se pueden cancelar y
entonces obtendríamos la expresión x
cuadrada más 7 todo esto dividido entre
3 x por equis cuadrada menos 1 ahora
bien algo que hay que tomar muy en
cuenta es aquellos puntos en donde estas
estas expresiones no es
definidas verdad por ejemplo aquí no
está definida para x0
aquí x tiene que ser distinta de 0 y
también x tiene que ser distinta de
aquellos valores que anule esto es decir
x no puede ser tal que x cuadrada menos
1 sea 0 o en otras palabras x no puede
ser ni uno ni menos uno bien entonces
otra bueno aquí faltaría ver para qué
valores de x x cuadrada más 1 se anula
verdad sin embargo veamos que x cuadrada
es un número mayor que 0 mayor o igual
que 0 y si le sumamos 1 entonces esto es
un número mayor o igual que 1 entonces
nunca se anula verdad así que estos dos
factores los podemos cancelar sin ningún
sin ningún problema entonces estas dos
estas más bien serían tres restricciones
tendríamos que agregar las a esta
expresión sin embargo no tenemos que
serían redundantes verdad porque aquí ya
estamos dividiendo entre x eso
inmediatamente nos dice que x no puede
ser 0 y también dividimos entre
x cuadrada menos 1 quiere decir que
justamente x no puede ser ni uno ni
menos uno entonces en realidad aunque
podríamos reescribir estas restricciones
están dadas implícitamente ya en esta
expresión muy bien y ahora si uno
quisiera todavía podría no sé distribuir
este producto verdad entonces esto sería
x cuadrada más 7 todo esto dividido
entre 3 x cúbica menos 3 x así que todas
estas expresiones son equivalentes desde
el punto de vista algebraico y hemos
terminado